some residents in northern Syria have
begun fleeing the military operation
Burnett Smith has more from Erbil it
looks like the fears of the Kurdistan
Regional Government here in Erbil are
already being realized as al-jazeera
understands at least a couple of hundred
cars have been heading seen heading
towards the part of the Iraq border
administered by the Kurdistan Regional
Government the KRG as Syrian Kurds
escaped the assault by Turkish forces on
positions that they hold the SDF assumed
it Syrian defense force holds in
northeastern Syria already there are
some 90,000 Syrian Kurds here in nine
refugee camps administered by the KRG
they are already full and over the other
side of the border we have our whole
camp which already aid agencies were
saying was a disastrous very very tense
atmosphere with a risk of an ISIL
resurgence II from within that camp and
there are detention centers administered
by the Syrian Kurds if those guards
minding those centers guarding those
centers have to go and fight for Kurdish
forces there is a fear of a breakout
from the detention centers and from the
refugee camp and a fear that those
people could head towards the border
here earlier we spoke to Talib Abraham
he says Turkey should focus on dialogue
with the Syrian government to resolve
the situation on the border the Syrian
government is not so happy in what
Syrian democratic forces are doing and
indeed they are enemies to the Syrian
government and we know that they are
separatist and they want to make their
own entity and to divide Syria but the
treatment of this situation
I mean Syrian democratic forces and
other Kurdish groups which are in the
eastern of your view fret is not by coop
I'm Syrian lands it is by working with
Syrian government to put an end to that
and I think turkey can work via
political means and by cooperation with
Russia Syria was Iran and will
to end the situation and this is of
course a situation a terrible situation
the eastern of Euphrates have nobody in
Damascus agrees Syrian democratic forces
but everybody is angry here from the
Turkish occupation and the Turkish
aggression against Syrian territory
swath of territory early aggression or
whether it was by airstrikes Russia is
trying to make a candied reconciliation
between Syrian government and between
Kurdish groups to the instant of new
practice to avoid any military
escalation and they want to reach any
kind of political resolution and at the
same time the Russians are very much
concerned to make the historic
reconciliation between Syrian between
Turkey between president Tayyip Erdogan
and between President Bashar Assad and
this should be reflected in a very very
positive and guilty situation of the
atmosphere of the whole atmosphere of
Middle Eastern and I think by a kind of
this strategic reconciliation if it will
happen between President Assad and
between President Recep Tayyip Erdogan
it will be it will put an end to Turkish
ambitions but it from Russian point of
view and from Syrian government
government point of view that it is
better to reach a resolution and
settlement for all problems for by
political means not by military ones
this issue but another issue from the
point from from the Syrian government I
think the size of Syrian government they
consider as I told you they consider the
Syrian democratic forces as enemies and
some Syrian high responsibilities
described with them as enemies and as
traitors and some people said we must go
to the war with them why because they
are killing Arabs they are displacing
Arabs from distress and they are burning
Pervis and killing the couple of farmers
they especially only for Arabs and
taking atoms by first to fight to their
side let speak to girón özkan he's the
People's Democratic Party representative
to the United States that's a
pro-kurdish opposition group in Turkey
he's joining us from Washington DC
thanks very much for speaking to us on
the al Jazeera news hour can I first get
your official reaction as a party as the
HDP party to the developments and the
news that Turkey has begun its military
operation into northeastern Syria well
this is absolutely horrific at this
stage where we've already seen footage
coming in from the region where there
has been relentless bombing along the
whole board civilian neighborhoods have
been hit and we're releasing very
graphic videos coming in of even
children being affected by the
bombardment and so I think the reaction
right now on the feeling right now of
all Kurds of the more than 40 million
Kurds spread across the region is one of
horror that one the Turkish government
would do such a thing and to the
international community will allow for
something like this to happen even
though the Turkish government is keen to
stress in a tweet in fact that Turkey is
not fighting the Kurds turkey is
fighting the PKK and ISIL and it's
saying the safe zone will protect our
borders and ensure the safe return of
refugees well there are several lies
just in that statement in itself firstly
there are absolutely no Isis fighters
who are active along that border that
they're attacking right now secondly it
is the Kurds they're attacking because
even in 2017 when the Kurdistan Regional
Government held a referendum for Kurdish
independence in Iraq and this is by the
KRG who have absolutely nothing to do
with the PKK actually have political
hostilities with the PKK and yet the
Turkish government was very hostile to
that decision very hostile to the
referendum and even threatened Iraqi
Kurds with starvation if they went ahead
with the referendum which they
subsequently did so the rationalization
is given by the Turkish government hold
absolutely no water anymore and say and
thirdly actually
the president here the US president is
tasking turkey with combating Isis and
taking over the anti-isis fight in Syria
and and actually taking control of the
Isis prisoners but how can a government
be tasked with such a thing a government
that allowed Isis to develop in the
first place according to American
officials turkey was implicit in Isis's
development in its first years allowing
Isis to roam freely through its borders
with Syria with right apologies just for
the sake of time let me jump in there
what is the SDF do now what are the
options for the SDF on the ground
because as you know it's being perceived
that the US president has abandoned his
Kurdish allies well throughout history
the Kurds have always defended
themselves and I think right now the
only option left for the SDF is to
defend themselves and their families and
their territories against this
unilateral action by the Turkish army
and so I think you know there aren't
very many options left for the SDF the
SDF have already their resources were
already very thin they succeeded in a
very efficient battle against Isis and
and defeated Isis to defend themselves
but they also did this on behalf of
humanity with very limited resources and
now they you know they have over 70,000
both Isis fighters and their families in
camps that they have to guard again with
very much very limited resources and on
top of this now they have to face the
second biggest army in NATO at all at
the same time so I think the options
left for the Syrian democratic forces
are very limited and the best thing I
think the SDF can hope for right now is
that the international community see
what's going on and hold the Turkish
government accountable for any thing
that happens to destabilize the region
right okay we thank you very much your
honors confer speaking to us from
Washington
let's continue with this and bring in
Joe Mack Ron he's a Middle East analyst
and fellow at the Arab Center in
Washington DC he's joining us from
Washington as well thanks for your time
on the NewsHour you've written that
Trump's decision to withdraw from Syria
is just another side effect of his
mounting troubles at home and abroad can
you explain that yes it's at some point
that's a distraction from his from his
domestic crisis and it's a same way how
he basically run away from his own
responsibilities we saw it and how he
did was dealing with Iran and house
doing with those Korea he bypassed
establishment he always repeated the
same thing he is an anti-establishment
president who doesn't believe in
bureaucracy who doesn't believe that any
of his advisers are smarter than him he
doesn't believe in empowering his own
emissaries around the world now nobody
takes seriously a Secretary of State or
the Pentagon say they all directly come
to trump to deal with him he likes to
put this order around him that he's the
the most smarter president the smartest
leader that everybody should come to him
he's he knows better than the others so
yes part of what's happening in Syria is
is his retreat his anti-trust of the
establishment his demeanor
at home and and his continuing crisis
that he doesn't believe he doesn't trust
his own government and when it comes to
what my previous guest was saying just a
moment ago that the international
community needs to hold Turkey to
account when it comes to this military
operation that has now begun in
northeastern Syria is that a viewpoint
that you agree with because certainly in
the past we've seen the international
community very divided when it comes to
the issue of Syria
I mean sadly there's nothing good at a
national community we live in a very
realist word now the first Cold War so
we not have this protection of civilians
all those things especially in Syria now
you have a game chess everybody want to
fill the the the the us vacuum if they
leave Turkey wants to have its own piece
of pie of of Syria of Syria you have
also Russia and Iran
so this is the hole at the game now
what's I don't see now I think Turk is a
bit reluctant to intervene they want
this civilian to basically push back and
we don't know what's the agreement with
us what's the limit of this incursion
what's the off limit that from spoke
about and yes it's not the first time
the u.s. basically gave up on the curse
they did the same and the Iraqi
referendum if you remember was Barzani
so so the curse they should and should
learn their lesson at and at this point
and they should decide if they should
shift alliances or no will they be
shifting alliances I mean the word right
how likely is it that we do see they're
getting their alliances because we know
that Moscow and Sergey Lavrov have has
offered to negotiate what the Kurds is
well on the Syrian government they did
they did last last year they negotiated
would be an agreement with the Syrian
regime but the Syrian regime refused to
give their full autonomy so they didn't
go as far and at that time the
trumpeters pressure told them you either
did with us or you did with Russia and
Syria so they basically went back so now
I think everybody is waiting a signal if
the u.s. is really withdrawing just few
meters fifty soldiers or fully living
the US and I think at that point the
curse would be ready to shift alliances
to make a deal with Russia but it might
be late because they already left the
border areas now they are empty for
Turkey to enter so I think Iran is
mostly waiting the Russian a green light
before going in since the u.s. basically
told them we are out we're not doing
anything
Iranian czar worried and then the
Russians will have to have a say and
what will happen because of the US is
leaving it means all the dynamic is
change and the russia turkey clash might
be coming in the coming months us
because now the syrian regime was
relaxed that the Kurds were next to him
they were mostly a neutral partner or
neutral player right now the Syrian
opposition's coming in there might clash
with the regime and not we have a new
dynamics that will change the political
process and I worry
basically Iran and Russia so we're still
not clear what will happen next
yeah we'll have to wait and see we thank
you very much for the time being Jo
macron for speaking to us from
Washington thank you